welcome to part 2 of my origami rose
tutorial if you're looking for part one
you can click the link on my hand or the
links in the video description or series
playlist above if you've completed your
origami rose base then all you need to
do is to follow along because I'm going
to show you how to close it up and
complete the rose now that you've
completed the rose base you should have
something that looks just like this and
this is the little square portion that
we flattened out so once you have that
you're going to flip the model over and
as you'll see we now have these four
flaps on the front and these four flaps
are going to become the petals of the
rose so as you can see we have four
petals in the Rose so before we could do
that we have to change this into
something that looks like this we're
going to add a few folds and we're going
to round off these corners here so that
we can close the entire model like that
and then we're going to interlock the
bottom and fold out the petals to
complete the Rose so to do that we're
going to work with one of these flaps at
a time and we're going to start with the
one on the left here now as you can see
we can kind of lift up this petal and we
could smooth it out underneath here on
this crease so what you want to do first
is you want to lift it up and you're
going to make a little crease here up
until that corner now you'll see when
you push in there you can't go any
farther so it'll stop right there and
what you want to do is you want to align
this edge here with the vertical edge up
top so you want to take your finger push
it until it's just like that and when
you do that this edge will also be
sticking straight up once you have it
like that we're going to take the edge
and we're going to pull it towards us
and we're going to align the edge with
this vertical edge on the bottom now so
lift it up push it down pull it towards
you and as you'll see when you do that
when you're pulling it towards you
of rounding it off on your finger so
we're rounding off on our finger there
and we want to align this edge now with
the bottom edge and in here now we're
going to make a crease so push down on
that fold and holding this here you'll
also see that we need to make a crease
on the outside here so you might need to
round it off and then you want to take
your finger and you want to make a
really good crease with your fingernail
so there we have completed one of the
petals now we're going to do the next
one so just rotate it clockwise and do
the same thing so lift it up here and
you want to push your finger all the way
until it can't go and it'll go to that
corner right there this edge will align
with the vertical edge and you'll also
see that you'll have an edge here
sticking straight up now what you want
to do is to pull it towards you and it
will round off on your finger and then
you want to align the edge with this
bottom edge on the on the bottom there
and you want to make a crease inside
there and then you also want to make a
crease on the outside here with your
fingernail so there we have to do the
next one
put your finger underneath there
press down like that all the way to the
corner and then from this point we're
going to take this edge and align it
with the bottom vertical edge take it
and just bring it straight down like
that hold it there make a crease on the
inside here and then you also want to
make a crease on the outside on this
fold make sure to make a really good
crease there with your fingernail
then you could lift it up and then we're
going to do the last one so stick your
finger underneath this flap and you want
to press down until you get to the very
end and this edge should be sticking
straight up in the air now again we're
going to pull this towards us until this
rounds off on our finger and this edge
here is going to align with the bottom
vertical edge then we can make a crease
inside here hold this there and also
make a crease on the outside here so
when you're done you should have
something that looks like this now these
might get flattened out that's not a
problem the creases will stay in the
paper and as you'll see we have made
these four new creases as well at this
point your model should look like this
and you'll see that I've drawn four
lines on the new creases that we've just
created and it's not the one that goes
to the corner it's the one next to it so
that's the new crease we've created and
I've drawn it on the front and also the
back and you'll see why in a moment why
those creases are very important for
folding the petals of the rose together
but for now what we're going to do is
we're going to as you'll notice the
petals here are actually folded this way
they're kind of folded upwards because
of the new crease we made but that's not
the way we want it we want everything to
be folded downwards and look something
like this so the corners are folded down
so to do that we're going to flatten out
the Rose a bit and you'll see that in
the center here we have a square because
of those new creases that we've made so
let me outline that so you could see it
a little better
so you should be able to see that on
your model what we're going to do is
we're going to fold downwards on these
four creases on these four lines here
and you don't want to crease it too hard
but just fold the model downward like
that and if you see it gets stuck like
this pop it outwards by pushing from the
inside like that and just give it a
round curve like that so just fold
downwards on those four creases make
sure nothing is getting wrinkled pop
everything out like that and do that
with all four of those lines you don't
have to crease it too hard just push
downward on it just like that make sure
nothing's getting wrinkled and it should
look something like this now what we're
going to do now is we're going to crease
on those lines that I have drawn and we
need to make those Valley folds so we
need to make them so that it's folded
upwards now you should have a crease
there so it shouldn't be too hard to
make that crease a little bit stronger
so just take that crease and run your
fingernail against it just like that and
you should see this petal sort of move
toward that one once you make that
crease sharp and do the same for the
other three folds so just crease that
really good you could hold it upside
down if you think you could see it
easier and it might have helped if you
did draw those lines on that crease
there so just make those creases really
sharp
so it should look something more like
this now okay at this point make sure
that your rose looks like this one and
that you have very good creases all
throughout the Rose especially on these
four folds here because what we're going
to be doing in this step is we're going
to be wrapping these petals in a
counterclockwise direction around this
center square portion and if you don't
have really good creases it'll make it a
little tricky so just make sure that it
looks like this and what we're going to
be doing is we're going to take one
petal and we're going to wrap it around
to the next petal like this and you're
basically going to be folding on that
valley-fold there so you want to join it
to the next one and hold it there just
like that and as you'll see if you look
from the bottom this valley-fold is
lining up with the pedal this petals
corner fold here so you see this lines
up with that corner there like that and
what you want to do from this point is
just make sure that it's a little
rounded so once you join it together
just wrap it around the center portion
like that
and see how it kind of got stuck here so
just take your finger and just round it
off like that okay then you're going to
just release those two and you're going
to take this one and touch it to this
one the same way we did so just hold it
on this one make sure that it's rounded
off and just press it around like that
to give it a little bit of a bend at
this corner here so then you want to do
the same with this one in this one
see now that's a cause of a problem so
what I did it was stuck like that so
just make sure that all the creases are
very sharp and that they join up
together otherwise you're going to have
a little bit of problem just joining
these pedals together so if everything
is nicely creased then you'll see that
we should be able to wrap all the petals
around so here we go just wrap the
petals around like that and it should
look like this on the inside
once you're done okay so what you want
to do now is to just look underneath and
make sure that everything is really
smoothed out if you have anything that's
wrinkled you might just want to take
your two fingers and just go along the
outside and round everything off and
make sure it's smooth also you can push
on the bottom there on that little
square piece to make sure it's flat so
what we're going to be doing now is
we're actually going to lock the bottom
of the rose this is the bottom and this
is the top of the rose so we're going to
interlock these four corners of the
bottom to do that we're going to fold in
a counterclockwise direction and we're
going to start with any one of these as
you'll see we have four corners so what
we're going to do you'll see that we
have a diagonal fold here so we have a
diagonal fold right here and if you
follow it all the way to this edge of
paper here is where you want to draw a
horizontal line so if you want to draw
on your model just like that that's fine
and as you'll see we're going to tuck
this in words like this on that diagonal
fold so you want to fold on this
diagonal fold and at the same time tuck
this towards the center and you'll see
that it will stop crease this really
good it will stop at that line there
because it's getting held up by this
edge so at that point you
want to just make a nice crease there on
that horizontal fold so you have
something like this then you're going to
go to the next one so just turn the
model you're going to go to this one so
same thing tuck this in words and you
want to crease on that diagonal fold and
you'll see when it gets to that point
where it meets this edge of the paper
here you want to make a horizontal fold
there and tuck that inwards to the
center now you'll see you have a flap
sticking up do the same with the next
one so just go to this one here we're
going in a counterclockwise direction so
spin the model like that and we're doing
this one now so just tuck it in fold it
on that diagonal fold and then make a
crease on the horizontal here and now
the last one which is here is stuck
underneath the first one that we tucked
you see that so the last one is stuck
underneath the first one so what you do
with the first one is you lift it off of
this this corner here just lift it off
it was like that you're just lifting it
out of the way for a second okay like
that
now you can tuck this in just like we've
done with the other ones so crease on
that corner tuck this in and at that
corner just make a horizontal fold and
crease it like that now you could put
this first one back in there you had it
like that just put it right back in
there and you'll see now we have four
flaps that are sticking up what we're
going to do now is we're going to
interlock these four flaps together and
we're going to do it in a clockwise
direction just check to make sure that
these are really tucked in well and that
you made good creases on all of these
folds
now if you've done the ninja star and
the origami box this is going to be a
piece of cake to you so we're going to
start with any one of these and we're
going to go in a clockwise direction so
you're going to start with the first one
and you want to just tuck it in and just
make a crease there like that so it
stays down then you're going to go to
the next one so this one here so that's
one and here's number two and just
crease that on the edge there then
you're going to do the third one so
here's the third one and just give it a
good crease so it stays down now the
last one is going to go over the third
one and underneath the first one here so
it's going to get tucked in right in
here over the third one so just bend it
like this and you're going to tuck it
over the third one and underneath the
first one right in there you see it and
then just give it a nice little crease
like that and there you go you've
interlocked the bottom so now all we
need to do is to unfold the petals if
you've made it to this point then
congratulations you've done an excellent
job all that's left to do now is to put
the final touches on the rose and this
step is entirely up to you I like to
open up the center of the rose like this
and to fold the petals back so they look
like that so that's what I'm going to
show you how to do now so to open up the
center I like to use my finger but you
might find it easier to use the end of
the pen I like to pull on the corner
here right where this little V is pull
outwards on that petal just like that
do the same for the other three so just
pull gently outwards like that
and when you do that you might find that
that little square base on the inside
there starts popping upwards again just
take the pen and you could poke
downwards on it to make sure that it
flattens out so just pull gently
outwards like that
and then what you could do is to round
these petals off so to do that just grab
the end here this corner and just fold
it backwards and at the corner here at
the the bend where it's bending you're
going to find that it gets stuck so what
you do is you just push inwards while
pulling backwards on it like that and
then you could round off the pedal you
might find it easier again to use a pen
and to wrap the petal around the end of
the pen like that so just fold backwards
and push on this corner here right there
and when you're doing this make sure to
hold the base very tightly otherwise all
of these will come undone so just pull
backwards like that so this is where you
need to push right here and then just
give the rose petals a little bit of a
curve so you get something like this now
you should probably spend a little bit
more time on it just to make sure that
everything is rounded off on the inside
to make a stem for your origami rose
take the top edge of an excess piece of
paper and fold it down to the bottom
edge and make a crease all the way
across the top unfold the paper and then
you're going to fold the top edge on to
the midline and you're also going to do
the same for the bottom leave a little
bit of space in between the edges maybe
like a millimeter or so and then you're
going to once again fold the top and
bottom edges next to the midline
and again you want to leave a little bit
of space because now we're going to
close both edges together just like that
and we're going to give the stem a
little bit of a twist but you want to
leave a few inches of space here maybe
about the the length of your rows like
that and then you want to twist the rest
of it give it a little bit of a twist
like that not too much because it'll
become weak and then when you're done
you could put this straight edge into
that opening on the base of the rose and
there you go you have completed your
origami rose thank you for watching part
2 my origami rose tutorial I hope that
you found the video is helpful now you
were able to complete your rose if you
had any questions comments feedback or
even a video response of you finishing
your rose leave it below in the comment
section also let me know what you guys
would like to see me do next if you
enjoy the video be sure to give it a
thumbs up by clicking the like button
below and subscribe to my videos for
further notification by clicking the
subscribe button above